Firdos has been walking for three hours
from one pharmacy to the next he needs
injections for his 70 year old mother
she has cancer you shouldn't be long
bothers the injections are not available
in the market the situation here is bad
nothing is available here pharmacies in
Srinagar are running out of medicine we
don't have 50% of our stock if the
curfew continues we'll run out of our
medicines and 10 or 15 days families
like these are stuck at home because of
security restrictions imposed by the
Indian government after it revoked the
region's autonomy last week phone lines
are down an Internet is not working
nobody tells us TVs are off everything
is gone mobiles are off this is not life
this is not the modern world this is all
gone I mean we are living in ancient
times this editor of an English daily
says she hasn't been able to reach her
journalist in the Kashmir Valley since
Monday she has filed a petition in
India's top court to ask the government
to lift restrictions on the media we
don't know the truth we are seeing a lot
of different reports and they are very
strikingly different versions coming out
which one is the the authentic picture
it's very difficult to say with
certainty the government says the
restrictions are temporary and are aimed
at ensuring law and order in the region
but the editors Guild of India say it's
concerned that they are making it
difficult to report accurately from the
region and people here say that that
vacuum is being filled by misreporting
and what they call fake news on the
internet fact checkers of the quint and
Indian online news websites say they
have found 13 instances of fake news
flooding the internet in recent days
since there is no communication we don't
know what's happening so I think when
you talk about propaganda the thing is
becomes very easy for anybody actually
on both decides to just peddle whatever
they want beat faith news beat the kind
of news that they want people to believe
in back in Srinagar through those
finally manages to get one injection for
his ailing mother but not all he will
now have to look elsewhere for another
day as people in India administered
Kashmir live under these unprecedented
restrictions in these uncertain times
Priyanka Gupta al-jazeera New Delhi